[Aplausos]
[Música]
aquí en visual político ya os hemos
contado en alguna que otra ocasión que
vivimos en un mundo que cada día es
mejor un mundo amigos en el que cada vez
hay menos pobreza y cada vez se vive
mejor
[Música]
un cambio que está llegando incluso a la
región más desamparada al áfrica
subsahariana en visual política ya os
hemos hablado de los leones africanos y
hemos prestado especial atención a casos
como el de botsuana o ruanda
[Música]
sin embargo nos faltaba contar cuándo y
por qué comenzó todo este cambio en una
región del mundo que muchos consideraban
perdida y condenada
pues bien amigos eso es precisamente de
lo que vamos a hablar en este vídeo de
eso y también de lo que podemos esperar
en los próximos años
[Aplausos]
[Música]
durante años a hablar de áfrica ha sido
hablar de pobreza extrema catástrofes
naturales y todo tipo de conflictos y en
cierto modo las cosas continúan así
fijaos en la región del áfrica
subsahariana viven ni más ni menos que
la mitad ojo la mitad de todas las
personas que sufren la pobreza extrema
en el mundo hablamos de casi 400
millones de personas
luego noticias así tampoco nos
sorprenden
[Música]
el mundo vive la mayor crisis
humanitaria desde 1945 la onu alerta de
que 20 millones de personas en sudán
yemen nigeria y somalia están en
situación de hambruna o en riesgo
inminente de caer en ella por todo esto
estoy seguro de que a ninguno nos
extraña encontrarnos cada dos por tres
con campañas de ongs que buscan recaudar
fondos para hacer frente a todo tipo de
catástrofes humanitarias en áfrica o que
los gobiernos destinen miles de millones
de dólares cada año en ayuda oficial al
desarrollo
mali y el sahel son zonas prioritarias
para la política exterior española y
para la cooperación española al
desarrollo de hecho amigos la ayuda de
los gobiernos es la más grande de todas
cada año van a parar al continente
africano
atentos unos 50 mil millones de dólares
y esto lleva siendo así desde hace
décadas
sin embargo lo cierto es que durante
años toda esta cantidad de dinero no
sirvió de mucho
echemos un vistazo por ejemplo a la
década de los 90
[Música]
mientras la ayuda internacional a esta
zona del mundo sumaba decenas y decenas
de miles de millones que pensáis qué
ocurrió con la pobreza creéis que se
redujo pues no nada de eso
entre 1990 y 1998 la pobreza no paró de
subir y pasó del 55% al 58% cada vez el
porcentaje de la población condenada a
vivir en la extrema pobreza era mayor
[Música]
pero como es esto posible pues porque
una cosa son las intenciones y otra la
realidad algunos expertos afirman que
durante años las ayudas oficiales
debilitaron a los productores locales
[Música]
las pruebas demuestran abrumadoramente
que la ayuda a áfrica ha hecho que los
pobres sean más pobres y que el
crecimiento sea más lento dambisa moyo
economista nacida en zambia y autora de
la obra la ayuda que mata por ejemplo en
tanzania era más barato comprar la leche
subvencionada de la unión europea que la
de los productores locales sin embargo
amigos con el comienzo del nuevo siglo
de repente todo empezó a cambiar
[Música]
el gran cambio
de repente cuando áfrica parecía no
tener remedio todo empezó a cambiar con
el comienzo del siglo 21 las
estadísticas se dieron la vuelta desde
el año 2000 la pobreza extrema ha caído
casi un 40% la esperanza media de vida
ha crecido en más de 10 años la
mortalidad infantil se ha reducido a
menos de la mitad lo mismo ocurrió con
las infecciones de vih en niños y
prácticamente con cualquier otra
estadística
[Música]
si nos fijamos en la economía vemos como
entre el año 2000 y el año 2015 las
economías de la ceca subsahariana
excluyendo a sudáfrica que es un caso
como vimos aquí en visual político un
poco particular crecieron de media por
encima atentos del 6% más del doble por
ejemplo que latinoamérica otro indicador
para ver cómo están cambiando realmente
las cosas lo encontramos en el turismo
[Música]
el sector turístico tiene algunas
características particulares que nos
revelan mucha información por un lado el
turismo tiene un gran poder de
transformación para los más pobres
gracias a que es muy intensivo en mano
de obra y por otro lado tenemos que
tener en cuenta que la gente no se va de
vacaciones a países en guerra con
hambrunas o epidemias cuando el turismo
mejora en los países más pobres suele
ser un buen indicador de que las cosas
están mejorando pues bien si vamos a los
datos es posible que nos llevemos una
sorpresa porque este sector amigos lleva
20 años dos décadas completas creciendo
a una tasa media anual ni más ni menos
que del 9% si parece que las cosas
empiezan a marchar
[Música]
pero llegados a este punto es muy
posible que os estáis haciendo una
pregunta yo desde luego me la hago qué
diantres paso para que se produjera
semejante cambio atentos a este gráfico
me parece que nos da algunas pistas
[Música]
pero vuelvo a existir que fue
exactamente lo que logró esta especie de
milagro pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
preparando el despegue
en los cambios son muchas las cosas que
influyen pero vamos a ver como en áfrica
se produjeron tres hechos que empezaron
a cambiar y creo que para siempre la
realidad de este continente el primero
de todos las remesas veréis en áfrica la
población crece muy rápido lo que unido
a las pésimas condiciones de vida en las
últimas décadas muchos africanos han
emigrado a países más ricos hoy estas
personas se envían cada año decenas de
miles de millones de dólares a casa
dinero que se utiliza en los mercados
locales o para montar negocios por
ejemplo son las remesas y ojo son mucho
más importantes que la ayuda al
desarrollo puede ser que la inmigración
sea una política solidaria pues eso
parece segundo muy importante marzo del
año 2000 el congreso de eeuu aprueba
finalmente una ley que había sido
impulsada por bill clinton en los
últimos años de su mandato es la
conocida como african road opportunity
básicamente una ley que está
y un acuerdo de comercio preferencial
que elimina los aranceles y reduce las
trabas al comercio para miles y miles de
productos procedentes del áfrica
subsahariana desde que fue aprobado este
acuerdo vemos como entre el año 2000 y
el año 2016 que no fue precisamente
bueno el comercio entre eeuu y el áfrica
sub-sahariana se ha multiplicado por 2,5
lo que supone un crecimiento del 6% cada
año y tercero tal vez la clave de todo
'china si tal cual como me escucháis en
el año 2001 china accedió a la
organización mundial del comercio la
omct y se convirtió en algo así como en
la fábrica del mundo pues bien lo que ha
ocurrido desde entonces ha sido
impresionante el enorme crecimiento de
china ha sacado a decenas y decenas de
millones de personas de la pobreza en
china pero también en áfrica tormentosos
roldán se pidió que hacen las clases nos
aporte indicios visión tópica aplicadas
[Música]
me explicó el enorme crecimiento del
gigante asiático ha hecho que este país
demandé todo tipo de productos materias
primas alimentos manufacturas de todo
muchos países africanos han aprovechado
para sumarse al carro desde el año 2000
el comercio entre china y africa se ha
multiplicado ni más ni menos que por 17
lo que supone un crecimiento anual de
casi el 20 por ciento desde el año 2009
china es ya con diferencia el mayor
socio comercial del continente pero no
sólo eso los chinos lo sabéis lo hemos
contado aquí también están invirtiendo
mucho dinero por todo el mundo
y áfrica no es una excepción
[Música]
en 2016 cuatro de cada diez euros que
los extranjeros invirtieron en áfrica
procedieron de china hoy hay más de
10.000 empresas de este país haciendo
negocios en el continente africano
empresas mayoritariamente privadas y que
se dedican a todo tipo de negocios y ojo
porque el número no hace más que subir
y amigos así es como áfrica ha
conseguido empezar a dar la vuelta a las
estadísticas el gran protagonista de
todo este cambio no fue ningún tipo de
milagro supraterrenal ni tampoco tuvo
que ver con la ayuda al desarrollo el
cambio lo produjo el comercio y la
inversión y ojo los propios africanos
parecen tenerlo muy claro no me creéis
pues fijaos los países africanos están
avanzando para completar las
negociaciones para una zona continental
de libre comercio entre 55 países a
principios del próximo año
la idea adoptada por la unión africana
en 2012 es crear un mercado único que
incluya la libre circulación de bienes
servicios y personas si así es en áfrica
están trabajando para llevar el comercio
a cada rincón del continente ahora bien
es evidente que no todos los países
están desarrollándose por igual pero
esto es algo normal ya lo hemos visto en
el pasado en otras zonas del mundo
siguiendo la estela de asia
llegados a este punto hay una pregunta
que creo debemos hacernos realmente
podemos soñar con el despegue definitivo
de áfrica mirad creo que muchos de
vosotros estáis pensando bueno todo esto
que me cuentan en visual político es muy
bonito pero no es algo generalizado
seguro que en áfrica hay países a los
que les va bien y otros a los que no les
va tan bien pues sabéis que esto es
verdad pero también es normal fijaos hoy
puede resultar chocante pero en los años
50 asia era tan pobre como áfrica tal
cual como lo escucháis sí lo sé viendo
ciudades como shanghai hong kong y
taipei es muy difícil pensar que hace no
tantos años eran tan pobres pero mirad
cuando corea del sur o taiwán comenzaron
a crecer no eran países más ricos que
ghana o senegal por ejemplo y china la
india o vietnam eran desde luego
bastante más pobres como han cambiado
las cosas
[Música]
después de todo esto podemos extraer
alguna que otra idea amigos los países
asiáticos tampoco crecieron todos de
golpe para nada mientras países como
corea singapur japón o taiwan despegaban
otros países como china indonesia o la
india permanecían sumidos en la pobreza
y luego tampoco fueron precisamente
modelos democráticos corea del sur o
taiwán fueron duras dictaduras hasta
prácticamente antes de ayer
singapur ahí está y sobre china que os
voy a contar resumiendo mucha pobreza
unos países más adelantados y otros más
retrasados dictaduras en fin me parece
que lo que vemos hoy en áfrica no es tan
distinto a lo que hace 50 años ocurría
en asia
[Música]
listos para despegar
si las cosas en áfrica están cambiando
de los 10 países que aparentemente más
están creciendo en 2017 5 están aquí en
áfrica
[Música]
si echamos un vistazo por ejemplo al
último informe 'doing business' el
indicador del banco mundial que mide la
facilidad para hacer negocios vemos como
de los 10 países que más han mejorado 4
son también africanos
es verdad la pobreza sigue siendo muy
alta y estos países se enfrentan a un
reto muy difícil hacer frente a un
crecimiento demográfico tan grande que
va a multiplicar la población del
continente en las próximas décadas sin
embargo amigos la buena noticia es que
todo apunta a que gracias al comercio y
a la inversión internacional áfrica está
encontrando su camino y puede estar de
una vez por todas a punto de despegar
pero ahora turno para ti crees que
áfrica emulará el desarrollo que ha
tenido asia en las últimas décadas
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta si te ha
resultado interesante este vídeo dale a
like y no olvides suscribirte a visual
polític porque vamos a sacar muchos más
vídeos un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]